أحد الأشياء التي
لا معنى لها بالنسبة لي وأعتقد
أن الإرهاب
لا معنى له أبدًا ، لكن في بعض الأحيان يكون
هناك نوع من الرسالة التي
يحاولون إرسالها إلينا وهي تركها بشكل
صحيح ، أعني أن الأمر يتعلق بأننا ذاهبون
لذلك هذا  ليس هجومًا للقول إنه اخرج
من هنا ، اخرج من هذا البلد ، وهو
أحد أسباب تعرضنا
لهجمات إرهابية ضد القوات الأمريكية في
أفغانستان على مدار العشرين عامًا الماضية ،
ما هي الرسالة التي تعتقد أن داعش
يحاول إرسالها  هنا ، أعتقد أن هناك
رسالتين أعتقد أن الرسالة الأولى
هي أننا فشلنا في تأمين
محيطك وهذا
توقع أساسي أساسي لأي من
عملياتك ، لذا عار عليك لأنك فعلتها وجدنا
تلك الفتحة وإذا تمكنا من العثور على هذه الفتحة
يمكننا أن نجد الكثير من الثغرات الأخرى
وأعتقد أن الثقب الثاني هو أنك أبرمت صفقة
مع طالبان لكنك نسيت أننا
سنناقش سلطات طالبان
بشأن كابول ، كانت كابول
دائمًا منطقة متنازع
عليها انقسموا
هذه هي الآن طالبان  هاء
rsus شبكة حقاني وداعش
وآخرين وستضطر إلى التعامل معنا
الآن لأننا اللاعب القوي ونحن متشددون
في ذلك